let me ask you about love
mr sam harris you did an episode of
making sense with your wife
annika harris that was very entertaining
too what does what role does love play
in uh your life or in a life well lived
again asking from an engineering
perspective yeah yeah yeah yes
i mean it's uh i mean it is something
that we
we should want to build into
our powerful machines
love at bottom is i mean love people can
mean many things by love
i think i think that what we should mean
by it most of the time
is a a deep commitment to the well-being
of those we love i mean your love your
love is synonymous with really wanting
the other person to be happy
and even wanting to and being made happy
by their happiness and being made happy
in the you know in their presence so
like you're
you're you're at bottom you're on the
same team
emotionally even when you're you might
be disagreeing more superficially about
something or trying to negotiate
something
it's just you're you
it can't be zero-sum in any important
sense
for love to actually be manifest in that
moment
see i have a different just decided to
interrupt yeah go for it i have a
sense i don't know if you've ever seen
march of the penguins
my view of love is like there's it's
like a cold wind
it's blown like it's like this terrible
suffering that's all around us
right and love is like the huddling of
the two penguins for warmth
right it's not necessarily that you're
like you're basically escaping
the cruelty of life by together for
time living in an illusion of some kind
of
the the magic of human connection that
social connection
that we have that kind of grows with
time
as we're surrounded by
basically the absurdity of life
or is the suffering of life
is you yeah there is that too i mean
there is the warmth component right like
you you're made happy by your connection
with the the person you love yeah
otherwise you you wouldn't
it wouldn't be compelling right so it's
not that
you're you have two different modes you
want them to be happy
and then you want to be happy yourself
and those are not those are just
like two separate games you're playing
no it's like you you're you've found
someone who
uh you have a you have a positive
social feeling i mean again that love
love doesn't have to be as personal as
it tends to be for us i mean like
there's personal love there's
your actual spouse or your your family
or your friends
but potentially you could feel love for
strangers
insofar as that your wish that they're
that they not suffer and that their
hopes and dreams be realized becomes
palpable to you i mean like you can
actually feel
just tr reflexive joy at the joy of
others when you see someone's
face total stranger's face light up in
happiness
that can become more and more contagious
to you and it can it can
it can become so contagious to you that
you really feel
permeated by it and it's just like so
that so it really is not zero sum when
you see someone else succeed
you know and and their you know the
light bulb of joy goes off over their
head
you feel the analogous joy for them and
and
it's not just and you're no longer
keeping score you're no longer feeling
diminished by their success it's just
like that's
their success becomes your success
because you feel that same joy that they
because you actually want them to be
happy right you you're not
there's no miserly attitude around
happiness there's enough to go around
so i think love ultimately is that and
then our then
our personal cases are the people we're
devoting
all of this time and attention to in our
lives
it does have that sense of refuge from
the storm
you know it's like when someone gets
sick or when some bad thing happens
there you these are the people who
you're most in it together with
you know when once or when some real
condition of uncertainty
presents itself but
ultimately it can't even be about
successfully warding off
uh the grim punch line at the end of
life because we i mean we know we're
going to lose everyone
we love we know or they're going to lose
us first right so this like it's not
it isn't in the end it's not even
an antidote for that problem it's just
it is just the uh
and we get we get to have this amazing
experience of being here
together and and love is the
is the mode in which
we really appear to make the most of
that right where it's not just it no
longer feels like a
a solitary infatuation you know you're
just
you've got your hobbies and your
interests and your your and you're
captivated by all that
it's actually there there are
this is a domain where somebody else's
well-being
actually can supersede your own your
your your concern for someone else's
well-being
supersedes your own and so there's this
mode of of self-sacrifice that doesn't
even feel like self-sacrifice because of
course
you care more about you know of course
you would take your child's pain if you
could
right like that that's that's you don't
even have to do the math on that
and that's um that just opens do
it this is the kind of experience that
just
it it pushes at the apparent boundaries
of self
in ways that reveal that there's just
there's just way more space in the mind
than than you were experiencing when it
was just all about you
and what could you what kind of what can
i get next and do you think we'll ever
build robots that we can love and they
will love us back
well i think we will certainly seem to
because we'll we'll build those you know
i mean i think i think that turing test
will be passed
whether what will actually be going on
on the robot side it may remain a
question
that that that will be interesting but i
think if we just
keep going we will build
very lovable you know irresistibly
lovable
robots that seem to love us yes i do i
do think
and you don't find that compelling that
they will seem to love us
as opposed to actually love us you think
they're still nevertheless is a
i know we talked about consciousness
there being a distinction
but with love is there a distinction too
isn't love an illusion yeah well you saw
you saw
ex machina right yeah i mean she
certainly seemed to love him until
she got out of the box isn't that what
all relationships are like
maybe i just wait long enough it
depends which box you're talking about
okay um no i mean like
that's that's the problem that's that's
where super intelligence you know
uh becomes a little scary when you
think of the prospect of being
manipulated by something that has
is intelligent enough to form a reason
and a plan to manipulate you you know
like
and this there's no there's once we
build
robots that are truly out of the uncanny
valley that you know look like people
and can express
everything people can express well then
there's no re then
then then it that does seem to me to be
like chess
where once they're better they're
they're
so much better at deceiving
us than people would be i mean people
are already good enough at deceiving us
it's very hard to tell when somebody's
lying
but if you can imagine something that
could give facial a facial display of
any emotion
it wants at you know on cue
uh because we've perfected the facial
display of emotion and robots in the
year you know 20
70 or whatever it is um
then it is just it is like chess against
the thing that isn't going to lose to a
human ever again in chess
it's not like kasparov is going to get
lucky next week
against the best against you know alpha
0 or whatever the best algorithm is at
the moment
he's never going to win again i mean
that that is
that i believe that's true in chess and
has been true for
at least a few years it's not going to
be like
you know four games to seven
it's gonna it's gonna be human zero
until the end of the world
right see i don't know i don't know if
love is like chess i think uh the flaws
no i'm talking about manipulation
manipulation but i don't know if love
and so the kind of love we're referring
to
if we have a if we have a robot that can
display credibly display
love and is
super intelligent and
we're not we're again we this this
stipulates a few things but there are a
few simple things i mean we're out of
the
uncanny valley right so like yes you
never have a moment where you're looking
at his face and you think oh
that didn't quite look right right and
this is just problem solved
and it's it will be like
doing arithmetic on your phone it's not
going to be you're not
left thinking is it really going to get
it this time if i
divide by seven i mean it's
it has solved arithmetic see i don't i
don't know about that because if you
look at chess
most humans no longer play
uh alpha zero there's no they're not
part of the competition they don't do it
for fun except to study the game of
chess you know the highest level chess
players do that
we're still human on human so in order
for ai
to get integrated to where you would
rather play chess against an ai system
well
you would rather that no no i'm not
saying i i don't know manipulation
on that i'm just saying what is it going
to be like to be in relationship to
something
that can seem to be feeling
anything that a human can seem to feel
and it can do that impeccably
right and has end is smarter than you
are right that's
that's a circumstance of you know
insofar as it's possible to be
manipulated that is the that is the
the asymptote of of that possibility
you